Jared Goff one of the quarterbacks in
Super Bowl 53 the other quarterback Tom
Brady things are going well if you look
at the standings for the New England
Patriots things are not going well
offensively for the team it's all about
a defense Chris that you've compared to
the 85 Bears in the 2000 ravens Tom
Brady yesterday after the game a game in
which the only offensive touchdown came
from Julian Edelman throwing a pass on a
gadget play Brady was a little pissy at
his Prescott answers Bill Belichick
style I guess he was a little pissy also
on WEEI this morning he doesn't weekly
spot there on the Greg Hill show and it
just it makes me wonder what's going on
where this is heading how much longer
he's gonna be there and will he make
that phone call this week or next week
to get Gronk to come back and even if
Gronk isn't at the point where he has
the weight on him to play he has to be
back by the last business day before
week 13 or he can't come back this year
ever right so you bring him back you put
him on the roster and you just feed him
protein shakes over and over again until
he puts the 20 pounds on then he's ready
for the playoffs
maybe I mean they certainly could use
them they just you know again I think
first off you know they're just not that
great on the offensive side of the ball
they have offensive line issues they
want to run the ball they can't do that
that's really what they're built to do
and then that's where a lot of their
assets and money are as far as that
position and doing it
mikheil hairy just getting back healthy
their first-round pick maybe he can help
their offense here down the stretch a
little bit but they don't have a guy
that can back you off in the pass game
and then when you can't run the ball and
pass protect all that well either it's
just tough to always overcome that
especially against really really good
defenses now they did enough yesterday
to manage field goals and they you know
they play the right complete full
football game Brady's never had to
really deal with this in his career so
I'm sure he's pissy but I think
ultimately the biggest thing to me Mike
too is you know like you have said with
Aaron Rodgers Brady knows what he's
doing and I think he's trying to just
hold the rest of the offense accountable
to like this is not good enough and he's
showing them like I'm really pissed off
so you guys should be pissed off too and
we got to raise our level and they're
they're good
after where they don't need to raise it
that much they just need to get a little
bit better to where we go oh okay they
can move the ball on the Raven sir you
know they can move the ball on the
Chiefs defense enough and the playoffs
and those type of scenarios too because
it doesn't look I mean you scored 20
points they're winning basically that's
where they're at right now you get 17 20
you're gonna win the game because of how
great their defense is playing Brady
said this on WEEI day as crazy as it
sounds we're still kind of a relatively
new offense getting familiar with each
other offensively are the strengths of
our team is our defense and special
teams so on offense we just have to take
advantage when we get opportunities
understand where our strengths lie and
try to play to them not giving short
fields not turning the ball over try to
take advantage when you don't read air
and score touchdowns that's kind of
where we are that's our team is right
you know it's honestly it's like it's
gotten full circle it's a little bit how
it was this himber to start his career
right it was man we're gonna run the
ball you know we're gonna just manage
the game offensively and Brady would
make a few big throws every game and
some big moments and he'd go man they
did it and their defense was really good
you know and then they're you know he of
course he started to get better and
better every year went by he just
started to take over whenever you wanted
but yeah I don't think the supporting
system around him offensively right
enough right now is good enough and a
him at age 42 he's not gonna be able to
just carry the team all the time week by
week and yeah they're gonna have to kind
of play that style here down the stretch
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports